how do you deal with failure and what's
your advice to young entrepreneurs
especially with regards to failure and
how to approach it you're going to fail
some things you're going to have some
Human Relationships that don't work out
you know fairly significant number of
people get divorced I mean you know
that's a very big decision to adapt turn
out badly but I think if you study
almost everybody and read read case or
you know personal history and you'll
everybody fails at some things right you
know particularly particularly when
you're younger I mean you know you do
have less experience in evaluating
humans and you know and just knowing
about whatever maybe businesses it is
not available I mean if you're healthy
particularly living in this country
there's gonna be there's going to be an
opportunities that comes around I got
turned on for the Harvard Business
School when I was when I got on the
University of Nebraska you know and I
remember you know I went to Chicago to
get interviewed this is when you
traveled on the train and so I spent 10
hours going there and this fella looked
at me and about 10 minutes he said you
know forget it Bell and now I got to go
back on the train 10 hours and think
what am I going to tell my dad what tell
my dad I mean my dad always told me I
could do anything you know and
everything now I've just got just gotten
turned down uh you know but it turned
out one of the best things ever happened
to me because then I went to Columbia
where Ben Graham wasn't in fact it
probably even affected who I married
because I took a one-year course at
Columbia and said two years at Harvard
and she might have found some other guy
during that time almost everything in my
life that looked like a failure has
either turned usually that's turned into
a success I mean it it the world isn't
over you know if you have bad luck in
health that's tough I mean there just
don't there's just no getting away I've
been lucky on that but but the other
kind of things if you're healthy and
you're bright and you know you've got
decades ahead of you you know if
something goes wrong if you find
yourself working for the wrong employer
and they're you know they're doing
things you don't approve of or they're
not treating you fairly you know the
world isn't over yet you know you just
go out and find somebody else
you're not afraid of failing you're
afraid of failing in front of other
people you will sing in the shower but
you won't sing on the street corner why
because of other people because they may
see you because they may laugh at you
because they may say look at that person
they're so dumb right you're not afraid
of failing not not just by yourself
you're afraid of failing and who was
gonna watch and so that becomes really
important because it now means you're
living your life based off of other
people's expectations and judgments and
maybe that's
people in your own family maybe that's
people you know maybe that's your mom or
maybe that's random people you're afraid
of the Judgment of unknown YouTube
commenters and leaving some kind of
feedback on your video telling you how
much you suck right we're afraid of the
people that we care deeply about and
their perspective and opinions on us and
we're also afraid of the the people who
we don't know yet who are just out there
in the world on the internet who might
come and leave negativity on whatever
you're going to be creating so you're
not actually afraid of failing you'll do
it all the time but it's failing and who
is going to see us fail
and so
it's a lot to unpack inside of that
let's start with
what is your big goal what do you want
to accomplish what mission are you on
who are you trying to serve who you
trying to help and in order for you to
go off and accomplish those things and
serve to your highest capability you're
going to have to do things that will be
scary where you're going to risk failure
right if you are never risking any kind
of failure then you're living your life
so small and so safe that you don't like
your life
if there's nothing in your calendar in
the next month that you are excited by
the that your heart's getting you're
you're scared like you're nervous right
you're like oh my gosh that thing's
happening if there's nothing in your
calendar that's like that you don't like
your life that that's honestly most
people
you're just photocopying your same life
over and over and over and over and over
again that's what most people wake up
and do I'm sitting here in the Costco
parking lot right like most most people
you just wake up and you're photocopying
the same day you had yesterday and last
week and last year that's not a life
so you have to be willing to risk some
kind of failure which would potentially
risk how other people see you and judge
you I used to not be able to record
videos like this I mean the first video
I ever recorded in public
was I was walking down the street at my
old house and I was challenged by my
agent he said you have to record videos
in public like Steve big feet is in
public are you crazy I can barely make
videos at home I'm going to now make
them in public like you have to do it
like okay great so I'm walking down the
street carrying my big video camera at
the time and
[Music]
I made sure I picked a really quiet
section of the street where nobody was
usually outside because it made me feel
like I was recording the video and doing
the task but there was nobody around so
I wasn't really doing the task and I
remember there was a male male uh male
woman who was dropping off mail and as
soon as I saw her and I felt like I was
in auditory range of her then I pulled
the camera down and then as I passed her
I started filming again
it's like I did the assignment Steve
look I found outside
Simon because I'm afraid of of a male
woman's opinion of me like she doesn't
even care about me she's she's living
her life doing her thing
[Music]
and so something like this now I'm
sitting here in a parking lot filming
and people are walking by and some
people are watching like what's this guy
doing
keep going you just keep making because
fear of other people's judgments cannot
be a good enough reason for you to play
small not anymore and if you want to do
great things most of the people judging
you don't like their own lives and any
judgment they have of you is just a
reflection of self
so there's a couple of hacks that I've
used to be able to get through it that
might serve you
number one is studying successful people
and anytime you study successful people
you find out that they failed along the
way to their success
a lot of times you may just see on the
surface just their accomplishments and
lists of what they've done and all that
and it could feel
imposing you know how are they so
perfect and I suck and I have all these
fears and insecurities but if you look
deeper into their story and maybe watch
some of their interviews or videos
you'll see that they struggled a lot and
they had multiple failures on their path
to success and I used to before my
channel came out I used to read stories
of different famous entrepreneurs and
how they got started and you know the
kind of zero to one story because it
made me feel like
it was possible
that looking at Warren Buffett now is
crazy you know it's like he's done so
much you can't relate but how do you go
from zero to one and what did he
struggle with and where did he fail that
was inspiring to say hey okay if he
could get through that
now me decades later with a lot more
opportunity in technology and resources
and I could do that you know I could do
something similar so that inspired me to
to get out of my cocoon and to be around
people who are doing amazing things
inspired me to want to go off and do
more it's also why I make videos like
this so that you can learn from Warren
Buffett and all the people that we
profile and because I think the more
that you're around that
the more you'll win I don't know Warren
Buffett personally you probably don't
maybe you do maybe you can text him and
ask for advice I can't not yet but I can
watch his videos and I can learn from
him and I can get better and I can
improve Myself by being around him and
the more that I watch his videos the
more I can think like him just a little
bit and and that's important because
that shifts you forward so being around
more successful people will will shift
you towards success even if they are
virtual through through a computer
screen through videos podcasts books Etc
the second thing is
teaching myself that I do difficult
things
and I think that's really important
because we've accepted fear as a good
enough reason for you not to do the
thing you've accepted other people's
opinions as a good enough reason for you
not to do the thing my trigger words I
call them play bigger triggers you come
up with the triggers that will allow you
to play bigger so if I say scary
difficult or hard then I go off and do
it because I want to be the person who
does the things that are scary difficult
or hard to myself and that's why I still
make videos that's why I'll write books
and speak on stage and find all of those
things incredibly scary difficult and
hard
so what is it for you and when you can
stop accepting scary difficult or hard
as a good enough reason like I want to
do it but I'm scared okay well that's
not a good enough reason you've already
set you've pre-decided that that's not a
good enough reason so you have to go up
and do the thing it's a scary difficult
heart you say it you write it you think
it you tell somebody else it as long as
that is the reason for you to put the
brakes on your life it's not a good
enough reason anymore it has to be
something stronger than scary difficult
or hard otherwise you have to go and
take action and you start to teach
yourself that you are the kind of person
who takes on things that are scary to
hold the heart so number one was being
around successful people
and study them and learn from them and
get mentorship from them even if it's
just through a video number two is that
you do difficult things and then number
three is
focus on service
and if you understand that the thing
that you're afraid to do is not just for
you it's for other people right if
you're an entrepreneur you're trying to
create a business it's not just for you
this sure there's selfish goals of I
want to I want to make money and provide
for my family and live a great life Etc
but above that needs to be service and
helping others that you're creating
something that's going to bring value to
other people that it's not just about
you making money but you're providing a
real service something really valuable
to other people that's going to make
their life better if I'm making videos
it's not just about me and numbers on
the channel it's about it's about you
and hopefully for for one of you watch
this video it has a big impact today
when I speak on Sage or write the Books
it's not about me it's about who I can
help serve and whenever you can deeply
connect to you can help serve
at least for me it gives me the courage
to go off and do the thing if I'm
terrified to speak on stage
I'll often look behind the curtain at
the audience and I'll try to find a
couple people's like I'm doing it for
that person I'm doing it for him I'm
doing for her I've got a message that I
can share that can help them
and that gives me the confidence and the
courage to go do the thing because we'll
show up for other people more than we'll
show up for ourselves and so when you
can tie what you're doing to other
people to Value to service to helping
them it'll give you more confidence and
courage to go off and do the thing that
you need to do and so I call that the
push and the hug so
the I do difficult things I do scary
things is the push like get up get out
there and do this Carmichael let's go
and the service is the hug like hey I'm
not I'm not doing this just for me I'm
doing it for for all the people out
there as well and some days you need
more of the hug some days you need more
of the push
and you just lean in on what you feel
you need most you know there are some
days when pushing yourself harder is not
the answer you need a hug and there are
some days where hugging yourself more is
not the answer you need to push
and so having a self-awareness and now
okay I need the push right now or I need
the hug right now and then going off and
doing that
will give you the momentum that you need
failure
failure is gonna happen
and the biggest failure again is that
the fear of other people seeing you fail
and as long as you live your life by the
expectations of other people you will
live small forever
and if you can flip it to say I'm doing
this to help others I'm doing this
because
I want to live a great life and I'm
doing this because I do difficult things
when you can make that shift happen you
start to accomplish your goals
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
I would encourage you if you're
interested in the field to do a few
things I'm still trying to make them as
intelligent as possible I would try to
stick with things businesses I thought I
understood I'd still get out that sheet
of paper and I'd write I'm doing this
because and just test my reasoning and
then I go back and read it a year later
and and see whether what you thought
would be true turned out to be true so I
would always check myself I believe in
grading myself on everything you know
doctors have post-mortems and they they
do it because they learn from
postmortems and business people don't
like to do post-mortems what I'm I'm I
can be on the board of a company and
they never wanted two years later to run
a check on how that decision turned out
because it it can be unpleasant but you
learn from post-mortems and you don't
want to learn it's way better learn from
other people's mistakes than your own
but you got to learn from a few of your
own too and the time to do it is when
you're young the allowance when I was a
little boy it was a nickel a week but I
like the idea of having a little more
than a nickel a week to work with and I
went into business very early
I started selling Coca-Cola door-to-door
I sold them door-to-door or sold
Saturday ink post Liberty magazine
ladies home Journey you name it
I think I enjoyed the game almost right
from the start
Own Boss
one thing I like about delivering papers
I got arrange the route I wanted nobody
was bothering me at five or six in the
morning
I read her papers a day and I made a
penny of paper but in terms of
compounding that Penny shirt into
something else people ask me what they
should take in business school and and
uh or even if they don't go to business
school what they need to know before
getting in business and I tell them you
know you have to you have to understand
accounting it's the language of it it
would be it's like being in a foreign
country without knowing the language if
you're in business and you don't
understand accounting so it it you want
to get as comfortable with that
as you are with the English language it
it's made me uh a lot of money because I
I listened to what Ray Dean had to say
53 or four years ago and have been able
to understand uh
uh what I was seeing on pieces of paper
what that told me about businesses and
the limitations of what it told me about
businesses I mean Henry Ford as you may
know failed twice before he started the
Ford Motor Company in 1903 I mean the
the test isn't whether you get the
greatest
business idea in the world the first
time out the test is whether you keep
learning as you go along what your
strengths are and what you can do for
your customers what you can bring
especially to the party you need a
genuine
a genuine desired day and day out
to Delight the customer
I've never I've never seen a business
and I've seen a lot of businesses but
I've never seen one that Delights the
customer
that that doesn't succeed I mean what
you want is that customer the next day
when they think do I want to rent a car
or do I want to buy some furniture
what goes through their mind you know
it's the place where they've had a great
experience
um I don't know what
I paid for this
type actually probably if somebody gave
it to me but for the purposes of the
speech I will say I I have no idea but
what I or the shirt I'm wearing or this
but I do know I will remember
how I was treated
when I bought it I mean you long forget
about the price but you never forget
whether you had a good experience or a
poor experience uh with the purchase
experience and I don't need to be in
Washington to figure out what the
Washington Post uh newspaper is worth
and I don't need to be in New York to
figure out what some other company is
worth it's it's simply it's an
intellectual process and the less the
less static there is in that
intellectual process really the better
off you are what is the intellectual
process the intellectual process is
is defining your level defining your
area of competence and valuing
businesses
and then within that area of competence
finding whatever sells at the at the
cheapest price in relation to value and
there are all kinds of things I'm not
competent to Value but there are a few
that I am competent to Value have you
ever bought a technology company no I
really haven't in 30 years of investing
not one I haven't understood any of them
so you haven't ever owned for example
IBM
marvelous company I mean The Sensational
company but I haven't known IBM and so
here is this technological Revolution
going on and you're not going to be a
participant gone right past me is that
all right with you it's okay with me I
don't have I don't have to make money in
every game I mean I don't know what
cocoa beans are going to do I don't you
know there are all kinds of things I
don't know about and that may be too bad
but uh you know why should I know all
about them I haven't worked that hard on
them in Securities business you
literally every day have thousands of
the major American corporations offered
you uh at a price and a price that
changes daily
and you don't have to make any decisions
you have to make nothing is forced upon
you so you there are no called strikes
in the business the pitcher just stands
there and throws balls at you and uh if
you're playing real baseball and it's
between the knees and the shoulders you
either swing or you got a strike hold on
you have to get too many call I knew
you're out in the Securities business
you sit there and they throw a U.S steel
at 25 and they throw General Motors at
68 and you don't have to swing at any of
them they may be wonderful pitches to
swing at but if you don't know enough
you don't have to swing and you can sit
there and watch thousands of pitches and
finally get one right there where you
want it something that you understand
and then you swing I've got this rule
the rule you know the first rule is
don't lose in the second rule is never
forget the first rule so it really isn't
so much having a lot of brilliant
decisions it's just not really having
some terrible ones and and and frankly I
did learn from Ben Graham how to avoid
ever having any disasters and
Investments it wasn't that you were
going to come up with the very smartest
thing but if you never have any any
significant losses you know some singles
and doubles will produce a lot of runs
before you get through leadership at
Berkshire
really consists of taking a bunch of
people
who win a baseball uh analogy would be
400 hitters and just handing them the
bat and just telling them to get up
their plate and take a big swing uh
there's very little to it beyond that
one thing I do is I send them a letter
the only thing I tell them
and this letter which went out January
20th 2003 it says it's been two and a
half years since my last memo now how
many big companies have do you have the
managers out there been two and a half
years since they've heard from the home
office it's been two and a half years
since my last memo
here are a couple things to keep in mind
and number one and this is number one
every time that this doesn't change it
won't change two years from now or four
years from now or six years number one
we can afford to lose money even a lot
of money
we cannot afford to lose reputation even
a shred of reputation
let's be sure that everything we do in
business can be be reported on the front
page of a national newspaper in an
article written by an unfriendly but
intelligent reporter
in many areas including Acquisitions
berkshire's results have benefited from
its reputation and we don't want to do
anything that in any way can tarnish it
last year Berkshire was ranked by
Fortune as the fourth most admired
company in the world this year we were
third in the United States they just
published it
it took us 37 years to get there but we
could lose it in 37 minutes
and that's the message I mean we you
know we we can lose money it does you
know nicer to make money but we've got
we'll figure out ways to make money
but we can't lose we can't lose a
shredder reputation
because you don't get it back if you
look around you at the people you admire
you know they have certain qualities I
mean you've got you've got friends why
do you like them you know generally you
know that they they generally they have
an upbeat attitude on life generally
they are generous people they're
humorous people they're people that do
more than their share they're people
that are thinking about something nice
they can do for you and all of those
qualities attract you and none of those
are are innate at Birth I mean you you
can acquire those and then there's other
people that turn you off you know and
and uh they have habits they take credit
for things they didn't do they don't
show up on time whatever it may be
they're a little dishonest about things
and
if you're looking at your life at a
young age like you are and you can
choose what kind of a person you can be
why not be the person you admire rather
than the person you can't stand it's so
simple so just write down the qualities
you like take your take your five best
friends why do you like them and just
write down those qualities
and you will find there's no quality
there that you can you can't have
yourself and similarly with the five
people you can't stand to be around but
those put those things down to turn you
off about those people and if they turn
you off about them why should you
possess them it's so simple uh you know
it's it's not it's not it's not like
some something complicated that you
think you should be learning
educated as investing in the stock
market I know but
it's it's enormously important to have
people work with you in life they're
going to work with you in life if they
like you you know and they may
occasionally I mean if you're in the
army or something you know you may work
for somebody that you don't like but by
and large
you're going to get the best out of
people if they feel good about you and
it's just so easy but you've got to
develop the habits early because you
can't say I'm going to suddenly become a
terribly attractive person when I'm 60.
it just doesn't work that way so pick up
the right habits now and
I will guarantee you if you actually
just write down those qualities and
think about it you will find you can
have every one of the attractive
qualities get rid of the ones that are
are negative and your life will be
different I like to read more than most
kids I really like to read a lot
by adding he gave me a copy of the World
Almanac and that was happened to me and
I can still tell you that almost
population was 214 0006 in 1930. some
numbers just kind of stick with you
and very early probably when I was seven
or so I took this book out of the Benson
Library called a thousand ways to make a
thousand dollars
one of the ways in this book was having
Penny weighing machines
and I sat and calculated how much it
would cost to buy the first weighing
machine and then how long that would
take for the profit for that one to buy
another one and I would sit there and
create these compound interest tables to
figure out how long it would take me to
have a weighing machine for every person
in the world the first books I read on
investment were actually in my dad's
office
[Music]
pretty soon I read all the books in the
office and read some of them more than
once a few years ago I went to Amazon
sure enough they had this manual there
so
or reliving my youth other guys were
going to Amazon probably in a fine old
Playboys or something but I bought old
movies manuals instead and when I got
out of school I started selling stocks I
was 20 years old at the time and looked
about 16 and acted about 12. so I was
not the most impressive sales person
anybody ever met but what I would do was
I I went through Page by Page looking
for possibly undervalued stocks yeah I
well I mean I've made a lot of mistakes
biggest mistake oh well not the biggest
necessarily the biggest but but buying
Berkshire Hathaway itself was a mistake
because Berkshire was a lousy textile
business and I brought it very cheap
I've been taught by Ben Graham to buy
things on a quantitative basis look
around for things that are cheap
and
that I was taught that we'll say in 1949
or so they made a big impression on me
so I went around looking for what
I call you cigar much of stocks and the
cigar butt approach to buying stocks is
that you walk down the street and you're
looking around for cigar butts and you
find this obviously this terrible
looking soggy ugly looking cigar one
puff left in it but you pick it up and
you get your one puff it's disgusting
you throw it away but it's free I mean
it's cheap and then you look around for
another soggy you know one puff
cigarette well that's what I did for
years
it's a mistake uh although you can make
money doing it but you can't make it
with big money it's so much easier just
to buy wonderful businesses so now I
would rather buy a wonderful business at
a fair price than a fair business at a
wonderful price but in those days I was
buying cheap stocks and Berkshire was
selling below its working capital per
share you got the plants for nothing you
got the machinery for nothing you got
the inventory and receivables of the
discount it was cheap so I bought it and
20 years later I was still running a
lousy business and that money did not
compound you really want to be in a
wonderful business because the time is
the friend of the wonderful business you
keep compounding it keeps doing more
business and you keep making more money
time is the enemy of the lousy business
I could have sold Berkshire perhaps
liquidated it and made a quick little
profit you know one Puff
but staying with those kind of
businesses is is a big mistake so you
might say I learned something out of
that mistake and I would have been way
better off taking
what I did with Berkshires I kept buying
better businesses I started the
insurance business to See's Candy the
Buffalo all kinds of things I would have
been way better doing that with a with a
brand new little entity that I'd set up
rather than using Berkshire the platform
now I've had a lot of fun out of it I
mean everything in life seems to turn
out for the better so I I don't have any
complaints about that but it was a dumb
thing to do I went into U.S air
I bought a preferred stock in 1989.
uh as soon as my check cleared the
company went into the red and never got
out I mean it was a really dumb I mean
it
um I've got an 800 number I call now
whenever I think about buying an airline
stock I call them up any hour that
fortunately I can call them at three in
the morning and I just dialed and I say
my name's Warren I'm an aeroholic you
know and I'm thinking about buying this
thing and then they talk me down I mean
takes take Taylor sometimes but it's
worth it believe me uh if you ever think
about that Airline buying an airline
stock call me and I'll give you the 800
number because
but
we got lucky in terms of how we
eventually came out on it but it was a
dumb dumb decision if you tell me who
your heroes are I can tell you how
you're going to turn out to quite an
extent by this point in life and I I I
have been extraordinarily lucky and that
none of my heroes ever let me down I
mean the ones I came up with
throughout their lives that I've never
felt that I've been let down in any way
with it number one was my dad and and uh
had a huge impression on me
my wife who was here is one of my heroes
I mean she is you know in terms of of
she's taught me a tremendous amount and
then and never seen anybody any better
with human beings than she is and you
can Yogi Bear again said you can you can
observe a lot just by watching and uh
I uh you know I I watched my dad and I
have watched her and uh I had a
professor Ben Graham back at Columbia
and had a huge impact on me so I have
been lucky and that I've had
terrific Heroes and they they haven't
let me down and and uh
that
that takes you a long long way I've gone
through one or two periods where we're
kind of tough in life but not I mean
every everybody's had had that but but
having the right Heroes will take you
right through it if you buy a business
if you buy a farm you know you go up and
look
you know every couple weeks to see how
far the corn is up and you know you
worry too much about whether somebody
says this is going to be a year of low
prices because exports are being
affected or anything like that you know
you buy a farm and you hold it for I've
got one farm that I bought in the 1980s
and my son runs it but
I've been there once you know I mean it
it it doesn't grow faster if I go on the
stare at it you know I can't cheer for
it you know more effort more effort or
something like that and I know there's
going to be some years when prices are
going to be good and so when the prices
aren't going to be good I know there's
yours when yields will be better than
others but about the farm and and uh
it's
it's it just doesn't I don't care about
economic predictions on it or anything
of the sort I do care that over over the
years it's well tended to in terms of
rotating crops and I hope yields get
better which they generally have in fact
that farm a hundred years ago would have
probably produced
30 bushels maybe 35 bushels of corn per
acre now in a good year you know it'd be
200 I mean
we really made progress in this country
that's one reason commodity prices have
go back a couple hundred years they've
moved so little is because we've just
gotten better and better at whether it's
cotton or whatever it's it's corn or
soybeans are all kinds of things that
and you and I have benefited from that
and so Apple was kind of like a farm
well it's a it's a long-term investment
and and if you owned if you own the best
auto dealership in town the best brand
and had something good running at you
you wouldn't drop by every day and say
you know how many people have come in
today or you know I think interest rates
are going up a little maybe it'll slow
down our sales or anything no you'll buy
it knowing there's 365 days a year and
you're going to own it for 20 years so
that's 7 300 days and you know they're
gonna things are going to be different
from day to day and year to year you
shouldn't buy it up the day-to-day stuff
it's important well speaking of
resources let's talk a little bit about
your decision to put your money with the
the Melinda Gates you are somebody
obviously who's
you know arguably not even arguably
definitively by numbers the best in the
world in terms of figuring out how to
allocate capital I mean dollars don't
lie and then put it to work and yet with
philanthropy you out you basically
outsourced it how did that well that's
true but you know when my wife had a
baby I didn't deliver it either I mean I
you know I I didn't fill my kids teeth I
mean you know I I Adam Smith in 1776
explained specialization of Labor and he
did a pretty good job on that and I feel
I'm very good at at piling up money and
and my wife was very good at unpiling it
I mean it's a very simple formula and
she was going to handle the philanthropy
big time and she did during her lifetime
at a at a moderate level but basically I
was going to turn it all over to her to
handle and I would pile up during my
lifetime and and she died before you
know earlier and and therefore I had to
make a decision as to what was the best
way to use a very large sum of money uh
and and get my goals achieved through
other people and there are other people
that are better than I am and all kinds
of things I mean a Roger here I mean you
know we're not going to get into a home
run derby
so so I believe in I believe in uh I I
really do believe in getting people that
are younger more energetic but also
experienced and in the case of Bill and
Melinda have their own money up as well
and they've got similar they've got
identical objectives really with me and
if I can get them to do the work and I
can keep having fun doing what I do I'll
do it and let's get in the game sure I
bought the first shares of Berkshire in
1962 and it was a northern textile
business destined to become extinct
eventually and uh it was a statistically
cheap stock and a terrible business
Berkshire Hathaway was closing Mills and
as they closed Mills it would free up
some capital and then they would
repurchase shares so I bought some stock
with the idea that there would be
another tender offer at some point and
we would sell the stock at a modest
profit and at one point the management
asked me at what price we would enter
our stock and I said 11.50
and the tender offer came out a few
months later
and it was a 11 and 3 8 was an eighth of
a point cheaper
and that made me very mad so I just
started buying more stock
I just felt that I had been double
crossed by the management and in May of
1965 but enough so we controlled the
company one of the reasons Warren
successful is he's brutal and appraising
his own past he wants to identify Miss
thinkings and avoid them in the future
but it was an accident that he chose
Berkshire Hathaway if the chairman
hadn't tried to cheat him out of an
eighth there wouldn't have been any
Buffett Dash Berkshire Hathaway history
if you're emotional about investment
you're not going to do well
you may have all these feelings about
the stock the stock has no feelings
about you
looking back it's interesting that
tender offer I didn't realize it but it
happened about five days after my dad
had died and whether that had affected
me or not I don't know well I was lucky
that I got started early I mean it
always helps me to get started early and
then and my dad happened to be in an
investment business so I would go down
his office on Saturdays and so at age
probably seven or something I started
reading these books that were around the
place and so I had a 15-year jump on
many people in a sense and that that
helped a lot and and I was always
fascinated by them I knew what I wanted
to do early and I think that's a that's
a huge Advantage too and then you don't
need you you don't need a lot of brains
in this business I mean I've always said
if you got a IQ of 160 giveaway 30
points to somebody else because you
don't need it in Investments what you do
need is emotional stability you have to
you have to be able to think
independently and you have to be you
have to be
when you come to a conclusion you have
to really not care what other people say
and and just follow the facts and follow
your reasoning and and that's that's
tough for a lot of people that part I
think I was just lucky with I was born
that way
in terms of emotions it's a truism that
investing emotions are your enemy
absolutely that when the Market's good
if you feel good don't if you feel bad
you should probably do it right but uh
how uh how how did you uh what was that
extra thing where uh so many will
acknowledge that and yet we saw in the
current crisis they they panicked while
you went into seemingly uh potential
disasters like GE and Goldman Sachs yeah
I can't really tell you the I mean I
didn't learn in school or anything I
just it never bothered me if people
disagreed with what I thought as long as
I felt I knew the facts I mean there's a
whole bunch of things I don't know think
about I just stay away from those so I
still within what I call my circle of
competence you know that Tom Watson said
it best he said you know he said he said
I'm no genius but I'm smart in spots and
I stay around those spots well I try and
stay around those spots and I I just
don't have a a problem if if uh if
somebody says you know you're wrong on
something I just I go back and look at
the facts and and
I think that I think that really is much
more important frankly than than having
a few points of IQ or or having an extra
course or two in in school or anything
of the sort you need emotional stability
by far the best investment you can make
is in yourself I mean that for example
communication skills I tell those
students that come that they're going to
graduate schools and business and
they're learning all these complicated
informal and all that if they just learn
to communicate better and both in
writing and in person they increased
their value at least 50 percent and now
I mean
if you can't communicate somebody he
says you know it's like winking at a
girl of the dark nothing happens you
know basically and and you have to be
able to get
get forth your ideas and uh and that's
that's relatively easy I did it myself
with the Dale Carnegie of course some
people wish I'd take it a shorter course
now that answers my talking later on but
it it's just hugely important and you if
you invest in yourself nobody can take
it away from you well I look at a lot of
figures just in connection with our
businesses I I
like to get numbers so so I I'm getting
reports in
weekly in some businesses uh uh that but
that doesn't tell me what the economy is
going to do six months from now or three
months from now it tells me what's going
on now with our businesses uh uh and it
really doesn't make any difference in
what I do today in terms of buying
stocks or buying businesses what those
numbers tell me they're interesting but
they're not they're not guidance to me
if we buy a business we're going to hold
it forever so we're gonna have good
years bad years in between years maybe
disastrous year or something here and
and uh we care a lot about the price we
do not care about the next 12 months
economic predictions just don't enter
into our decisions Charlie mugger my
partner I in
you know 54 years now
we've never made a decision based on an
economic prediction we make business
predictions about what individual
businesses will do over time and we
compare that to what we have to pay for
but we have never said yes to something
because we thought the economy was going
to do well in the next year or two years
and we've never said no to anything
because we're right in the middle of a
panic even if the price was right you
know how do you turn failure into a plus
uh and it's true when I was at the
University of Nebraska one day I was
reading the daily Nebraskan
and it said in Room 300 or something at
three o'clock there will be this panel
of three uh uh professors here at the
University and they're going to award
the Nathan gold scholarship I don't know
whether you're still do you still have
that around and at the time
uh it said it would give you 500 to go
to The Graduate School of your choice I
don't know whether it's changing amount
but but that that was it so I read this
and I went there to this room at three
o'clock that day or whatever it was and
I walked in the room
and there were the professors
and I was the only student that showed
up I mean it really got to him I mean
they were stuck they you know they kept
waiting and looking at their watching
hoping there'd be more candidates but
there no one came in so I won 500 by by
default and
those are usually my biggest triumphs
when nobody else shows up
and so here I was I had 500 to go toward
any it wasn't it wasn't the limiters any
any graduate school for a master's
degree so I applied to Harvard my dad
wanted me to
and
I shortly heard from Harvard
and they said go to Chicago and meet
this fellow running that who interviews
applicants from the Midwest
so I got on the train and that's what
you did in those days and I spent on 10
hours on the Burlington going to Chicago
then I transferred to another little
Interurban train to go up to this
Country Day School where this fellow was
the Headmaster and he was the big
interviewer for Harvard
and I got there and after about
10 minutes he he said better think about
something else that uh you know he uh
come back later on I was I was 19 at the
time and uh I looked about 12. you know
and and I and I acted about eight uh it
was not a great combination uh but so he
he said forget it so I spent I took the
little Interurban train back to Chicago
and I took the 10-hour train back to
Oman all the time you know what do I
tell my parents you know it's kind of
embarrassing uh but
it was it was the luckiest thing ever
happened to me because
if I'd gone to Harvard I would have gone
to a two-year
business school i i instead applied to
Columbia where I could graduate in one
year and get a master's degree
luckily
that by the accident of it and being in
the Nebraska National Guard which did
not get called up for the Korean War
I missed going in the Korean War
I
I got to meet Ben Graham and which had
an enormous effect on me subsequently
and I probably got my wife that way
because she was going to Northwestern
and I was able to put on sort of a full
court press because I got out in one
year and otherwise uh she'd she'd have
met some other guy I mean I I got her
before the competition showed up and uh
so it worked out wonderfully it couldn't
have worked out better and that's been
that's been my life basically I mean it
the things you know you will get some
disappointments you know uh but if I
knew every decision I was going to make
was going to be perfect it would not be
as much fun to be like playing golf and
knowing you're going to hit a hole in
one on every hole you wouldn't play golf
if every time you got on a tee you just
took a swing and the ball ended up in
the hole you know be fun for a few days
you get on TV but it the game would not
be any fun so it's failure you know
and I wouldn't even consider them
failures but they're mistakes or
whatever you want to call it they're
they're part of the game and in the end
you know you go on and and we've made
plenty of mistakes in business we'll
make plenty more and then you know the
Babe Ruth and you know for a long time
it subsequently got eclipsed by a few
fellows but uh he held the record for
strikeouts and I also the record for
home runs and was the highest paid
baseball player until the modern era
came along yeah so it's it's part of the
game if you take big swings you know you
yeah it may it may you're going to miss
sometimes I would like to tell you of
two women
oh that each sold the business
to Berkshire Hathaway uh to me actually
for many many many millions of dollars
both of them started with twenty five
hundred dollars by a coincidence was the
exact same amount it was everything they
had in the world and one of them
was a woman
who landed in Seattle in 1917
couldn't speak a word of English
had a tag around her neck
the tag said uh
Fort Dodge Iowa
the Red Cross
daughter in a Fort Dodge where she was
reunited with her husband who'd come to
the country a couple of years earlier
and she lived in Fort Dodge for two
years and as she put it
she felt like a dummy
she couldn't pick up the language she
couldn't learn a word
and so she decided she and her husband
decided to move to Omaha
so they came to Omaha
in 1919
and there she found a
small colony of Russian Jews so she
started feeling more at home and then as
her oldest daughter went to school
she would come home this daughter
Francis
and she would teach her mother the words
she'd learned in school that day
and this woman Rose blumpkin
spent 20 years
saving money
bringing first her siblings over
her mother and father
fifty dollars at a time she sold used
clothing to do it
she had four children during this period
and by 1937 after 20 years
she'd save twenty five hundred dollars
she went to Chicago
and she bought what she could have
furniture her dream and always been the
open a furniture store
and this woman without who had never
gone to school one day in her life
with twenty five hundred dollars
but with the same spirit that the people
in this room had
about having a dream
and working to accomplish that dream
she built a business
which she sold to me
in 1983 for
60 million dollars approximately in
which
but you did a billion and a half dollars
worth of business last year
the fourth generation is working in that
business
this woman Rose blumpkin
lived well she she worked for me until
she was 103. and then I'm not said then
she retired and she died the next year
which is a lesson to all of berkshire's
managers that
premature retirement you know nothing
you can't tell what's going to happen
but Mrs B
with her twenty five hundred dollars
one further fact about her
she could not read or write
and she went into a Furniture business
and she didn't bring anything in unique
in Furniture but she brought a
determination to succeed
she knew she could outwork anyone else
she knew that she cared about her
customers
she worked at very low gross margins but
she built this incredible business Brian
what do you consider the most important
quality for an investment manager
it's the temperamental quality not an
intellectual quality you don't need tons
of IQ in this business I mean you have
to have enough IQ to get from here to
Downtown Omaha but uh but uh you do not
have to be able to play
three-dimensional chess or be in the top
leagues in terms of bridge playing or
something of the sort you need
a stable
personality you need a temperament
that neither derives great pleasure from
being with the crowd or against the
crowd because this is not a business
where you take polls it's a business
where you think
and Ben Graham would say that you're not
right or wrong because a thousand people
agree with you and you're not right or
wrong because a thousand people disagree
with you you're right because your facts
and your reasoning are right how do you
know when to throw in the towel on an
investment or a business when you're
throwing the towel on a no investment or
business business yeah well you what you
know you're doing too late
I went in the textile business by
accident in 1965
and I threw in the towel about 20 years
later and that was about 20 years too
late
the there's a great tendency to want to
uh hold on justify old decisions I mean
that's a human human trait and uh
what when you really know you've got a
bad business is when you have a good
manager and you're getting bad results I
mean when you when you're when you're
getting bad results with a bad manager
you still have to examine the question
of whether you know you can get better
results if you get a better manager
usually you can't you know I've said in
the past you know when a when a
management with a reputation for
excellence
Encounters of business with a reputation
for bad economics it's the reputation of
the business that remains intact and and
I've proved that many times uh
there are businesses that are just plain
tough you know and there's the guy
there may be too many competitors but
there's reasons why they don't drop out
there's reasons well we we started out
in textiles and we made over half of the
uh the linings for men's suits in the
country and we we went through World War
II and got Awards and and Sears Roebuck
named us their supplier of the year and
all of that sort of thing and then we'd
say Well we'd like to increase the price
of of these Linings a quarter of a
percent a yard and seriously must be
ought to be reminders 10 other guys that
will sell them to us at the old price
and nobody ever went into a Sears store
and said I'd like a a blue surge cert uh
blue shirt surge suit with a half away
lining you know it didn't exist we had
no connection to the consumer and there
are lots of lousy businesses you know
and there's lots of wonderful businesses
and or my job over the years has been to
try and figure out which is which and
I've made plenty of mistakes I bought a
company called Dexter shoes in the early
90s I paid 400 plus million dollars for
it and it it made a lot of money before
I bought it but you know as soon as I
bought it they pulled some switch or
something
immediately he started losing money and
uh and it was because of foreign
competition so on or it was maybe it's
because I owned it I don't know uh and
it went to zero and the worst thing was
that I paid for it in stock so that 400
million in stock I gave at the time is
uh now worth about five billion so it uh
so uh every time Berkshire stock goes
down I feel a little bit better because
of my opportunity loss on this business
but you know when I looked at Dexter's
shoe they had a good position in
retailers they turned out good shoes
they had a great Workforce all kinds of
things but I just forgot one thing that
that they weren't going to make shoes in
the United States anymore so you make
you make mistakes and it does pay to
recognize quickly when you've made them
if you've got a good person running a
business and it isn't making any money
uh you know you're in the wrong business
and and you've got to face up to that
when you get to my age you will not
measure how well you've done by how much
money you've got I can guarantee that
you'll all do fine on money anyway I
mean uh you know think about it seven
hours a day
you know you're in a bed you got exactly
the same mattress I've got if you don't
we'll sell it to you at the furniture
mark you know I mean so so that I mean
we're on a parody I can't I can't outdo
you you know in terms of my sleeping
enjoyment you can you can match it by by
buying this mattress which will give you
a special price on just mention my name
we eat at the same places you know we
eat a Dairy Queen particularly if you're
in my position because we own it but but
we eat dolls in Burger King and and when
I leave here I'll stop by a fast food
place I mean I had a 10 year old car up
until about a year ago you know and it
just doesn't make any difference to me
and they they all work we live in a
place that's warm in the winter and it's
cool in the summer and we watch the
Super Bowl on big screen TV you do what
I do it you know we dress more or less
the same I mean I pay more for my
clothes but they look cheap when I put
them on so we're really on we're on a
parody yeah so so the money isn't going
to be that big a deal everybody in this
country is going to you know that with
the intelligence this group had the
energy you have you're going to do well
so what's the difference you know what
really counts well I would say that you
will measure health is enormously
important and that's a matter of a fair
amount of luck I mean you know so I
won't I don't want I'm not sure changing
it I'm just saying you can't do too much
about that but
you will measure your success in life
by whether by how many and extent
whether it's the people you want
at 70 or whatever the age may be you'll
measured by how many of them really love
you you know in the end I mean you can't
you know you you can't buy love I mean
it doesn't work you buy sex you can buy
testimonial dinners you can buy your
name on buildings you can do all kinds
of things but the you know the only way
you get to be you know love is to be
lovable it's kind of irritating actually
you've got a lot of money it'd be more
fun to just write out a check for a
million dollars that's everybody you
know from now on loves me but it doesn't
work that way and in fact it the only
way is to be is to be lovable and and
you know I've got this friend
who uh who came out of Auschwitz and had
at least one member of the family die
there
and
what is it now it's uh
60 years later
you know she's still when she looks at
people it's a polished you when she
looks at people
the question she asked herself in
determining who she really trusts as
friends the one question in her mind is
would they hide me
now when you get to be 70
. if you've got a lot of people that
would hide you you've had a successful
life I know people who have a tremendous
amount of money no one would hide their
own kids wouldn't hide them I mean they
they really wouldn't I mean their
business associates wouldn't or anybody
else if it really came down to it and
all that they they don't have anybody's
respect they've got their attention
maybe with money or something of the
sort but they they nobody loves them and
uh my friend Tom Murphy at Campus of hdb
I mean dozens of people would hide Murph
you know all kinds of people would would
hide my wife you know
that uh Ben Graham A lot of people my
dad it would have had a number and then
like I say that I can I can tell you
people that uh you know everybody May
pay homage to them and the kids may put
up with them and hope they don't change
their will or something but the truth is
that nobody would hide them and if
you've got a lot of people that would
hide you
when you get to be 70 uh you will have
had a very successful life everything
you do learn is cumulative I mean that
doesn't mean that Industries stay good
forever or businesses stay good forever
but but learning to think about business
models what I learned at 20 is useful to
me now what I learned at 25 is useful to
me now and so
it's not it's not so it's not a field
that changes
dramatically in terms of the underlying
principles it's like physics I mean
there's underlying principles now
they're doing all kinds of things with
physics they weren't doing 50 years ago
but but if you know the if if you've got
the principles if you know what makes a
good business if you know what makes a
good manager you know if he knows what
makes a a good product
uh
and you learn that in one business you
can there is some transference to other
businesses if you go along and you learn
what things you you're not going to
understand I mean
knowing what to leave out is just as
important as knowing to focus on and uh
I don't think I can win every game you
know somebody said how do you beat Bobby
Fischer you play him any game except
chess so I don't play Bobby Fischer
chess
that and what you're not good at you
know the most important thing
uh
aside from the things I've talked about
already is is really who you associate
with you want to associate with people
that are better than you are I mean
basically you'll go in the direction of
the people that you associate with and
and you want to have the right Heroes uh
you want people if you want to emulate
somebody you better pick very carefully
who you want to emulate and uh and one
obviously you can't pick your parents uh
they're going to have enormous influence
on you but you don't get a choice on
that but you get choices as you go down
the line and you
who you uh who you admire who you who
you want to copy and the most important
for most people in terms of that
decision is their spouse it's also
important in terms of a partner in
business with the partner in life is
is the most important one you want to
pick a spouse that's a little that's
better than you are
and then he or she and hopefully and you
hope they don't figure it out too fast
all of you in this room
have the brains to do extremely well in
life
you've all got the energy to do
extremely well in life and then the
question is how do you apply it if
you've got a 200 horsepower motor you
get 200 horsepower out of it you get
your full potential or do you get 100
horsepower or 50 horsepower
now there's two things that can hold you
back
in getting the full horsepower out of
your your engine whatever it may be all
of you have big enough engines
and one of those is a lack of education
but that probably isn't going to happen
to very many people in this room if you
did have a lack of Education if you
didn't if you didn't have a chance to
get a decent education in life it
wouldn't make any difference what that
potential was because you'd never unlock
it but the second most important thing
and equally as important
is in terms of the habits that you
develop in terms of what you do with
yourself
when we
hire people we look for three qualities
we look for integrity we look for
intelligence and we look for energy
but if they don't have the first one
Integrity the other two will kill you
because if you're hiring somebody
without Integrity you really want to be
dumb and lazy don't you I mean the last
thing in the world you want for them is
to be smart and energetic so smart and
energetic only goes with Integrity you
can't change your IQ or how far you
control football or how high you can
jump or the color of your hair very
easily but you can elect
to have integrity that matches anybody
else's and if you match that with
intelligence which you have and energy
which you have
you will get an extraordinary result and
you'd be very foolish to sell me 10 of
yourself for fifty thousand on the other
hand if you don't match it with that
your potential will in a significant
part go unused what other habits did you
cultivate in your 20s in your 30s that
you now see as being foundational to
your success as a business person
well I
I knew a lot about what I do
uh when I was 20. I mean I I really read
a lot and and uh I aspired to learn
everything that I could about the
subject so intellectually I knew a lot
I did not know a lot about human
behavior I mean that that you can't
learn really out of reading books but
it's it's very important to understand
people and uh I say to the students
you know just imagine you could buy or
you or you could be given 10 of the
future earnings of one person that you
know among everybody you know now are
you going to pick the person that's the
smartest I got to pick the person that
can dance the best or that can run the
fastest or anything like that the right
height no anything no no there you're
gonna you're gonna pick the person that
has the right habits that that is
cheerful generous
gives other people credit for what they
do you know and when you look at all of
the qualities that you admire in other
people which would cause you to pick
that person say to yourself which of
those qualities can't I have myself
because they are
you know you determine whether you have
them so just write them down on a piece
of paper who is the person that you
admire the most or like the best why do
I like them and just write down and then
say which of these can I do myself and
the truth is you can do them and then
you also if you really want to carry it
to the next extreme you pick the person
you dislike the most and why do you
dislike that person you know and you
know they always they're never fair
about things basically they always claim
more credit than they're doing
everything and write down those
qualities and say if you dislike that in
some other person why in the world would
you want to have those yourself so you
just get rid of those and it's a pretty
simple thing to do but you want to be
the person that if you could pick your
best friend you know that you would have
the same qualities I'm 72 I'm getting
Social Security now so I'm you know I I
I I should be in Florida you know
pushing shuffleboard around or something
of the sort but but but I do what I can
do anything in the world I want to do
but what I want to do is run Berkshire
Hathaway now why do I want to run it
that way
a I get to paint my own painting you
know I go down there every day and I
feel like you know I feel like
Michelangelo they're you know working on
the Sistine Chapel or something nobody
else may think it's a great painting but
I get to paint my own painting I do not
have people second guessing me I do not
have been people saying why don't you
use a little more red paint than blue
paint why don't you paint a Seascape
instead of a landscape I get to do my
own thing I get the it's it's it's a
form of creativity it's it's exactly
like somebody feels it's a professional
golfer or somebody feels it's a painter
they're not doing it for the money
primarily uh we've got a company flight
safety where the trains more pilots than
anybody in the world flight safety is
run by an 85 year old man Al Yoshi Al
started the company with ten thousand
dollars in 1951 it now trains four or
five times as many Pilots as
non-military Pilots as any as anybody in
the world
and he is there at 85 and then it's a
matter of public record he's got a
billion dollars worth of Berkshire
shares he works seven days a week he
loves it and he loves it for the same
reason then I love what I do he gets to
do it his way he buys these big
simulators that you train pilots in he
doesn't have to check with me as to
whether to spend 15 million dollars for
a simulator he doesn't ask me he knows
so much more about it than you know than
I do why in the world would he ask me
well I can't tell what kind of a plane
I'm at you know what I'm flying around
and and Al is spending a couple hundred
million dollars a year on simulators uh
suspending Berkshire Hathaway money and
he never checks with them all he's never
had to come to Omaha for any kind of
meetings he runs his own business and
that's what he loves in life and I let
him do it I mean that's my contribution
to it is is really turning loose his
energies and you know they were properly
directed before we bought the company
seven or eight years ago why do why
should I think that you know he couldn't
keep running it after that and like I
said 85 he's still running it and that
feeling of ownership is really
extraordinary and it's so much better I
mean it's the way I like to work uh and
it's the way you know it's the way uh
Susan jock likes to work it's the way Al
Yoshi likes to work somebody once said
that the chains of habit are too light
to be felt until they're too heavy to be
broken
I had been terrified of public speaking
I couldn't do it I'd throw up
and I know if I didn't cure it then I
never cared
and so I so I'd add in the paper for the
Dale Carnegie of course which worked on
developing her ability to speak in
public and I went down there
a good smile has the same effect as a
puppy's tail they made us do all these
crazy things to get out of ourselves and
so we stood on tables and did all kinds
of things
[Music]
[Applause]
if I hadn't have done that my whole life
would have been different
so in my office you will not see the
degree I got from the University of
Nebraska you'll not see the Master's
Degree I got from Columbia University
but you'll see the little award
certificate I got from the Dale Carnegie
of course you have over a hundred
billion dollars of cash Berkshire does
it yeah
Berkshire has over 100 billion in cash
and you say that you always want this
company to be a fortress so how much
cash should an ordinary investor have on
a percentage basis do you think it
depends on their personal situation of
it it uh
if
you're working in something where you're
you're living off your your your
paycheck from week to week you want to
have a little cash around and you
certainly don't want to have a credit
card that's maxed out or anything like
that uh but if you know if if your house
is paid off if you don't have big living
expenses you got a portfolio of of
decent Diversified businesses
uh
I don't really need any cash decent
genes for certain things and in my own
case I was sort of wired for Capital
allocation and being wired for Capital
allocation a couple hundred years ago in
Nebraska wouldn't have been a thing uh
and and even now being born in various
parts of the world it wouldn't have been
much but here I was in this
soon to be very rich capitalistic system
and and it just so happened that what I
did paid off enormously in a market
system like we have and I if I'd had a
talent in some other area that was way
less commercial I mean I would have I
would have had a good time doing it but
it wouldn't have paid off like this but
of course Jay said it perfectly when he
talked about you know he's in a
recording for himself and the money
comes afterwards I mean I I got to do
what I love I mean and it doesn't get
any luckier than that if if and you can
spend your lifetime and I'm 80 now and
doing things you love every single day I
mean I would be doing what I did what I
do now and I would have done it in the
past if the payoff had been in seashells
or sharks teeth or anything else it
if you can go to work every morning I
tap dance to work you know and I come
down and I every day is exciting I I was
terrified for example both in high
school and college I don't know when it
started but I became terrified of public
speaking and uh I just couldn't do it I
mean I I and so I arranged all of my
classes so I never had to do any public
speaking and I got to Columbia and I saw
an ad in the paper uh for Dale Carnegie
course and I went down it was somewhere
in the mid 40s and I gave the guy a
check for a hundred dollars and I went
back and stopped payment I lost my nerve
and then I came out I got out of
Columbia actually when I was 20 and I
came out to start selling securities in
Omaha and I realized I had to get up and
be able to get up in front of people I
couldn't go through life this way so I
saw an ad again in the uh local paper
that there was a day on Carnegie of
course being given I went down and I
gave the fellow a hundred dollars in
cash and I became associated with 30
other people in the class we couldn't
stand up in front of a group and say our
own name I mean it was we were it was
pathetic but that class changed my life
in a big way as a matter of fact they
used to give a pencil every week for
whoever did the most with what they
learned the previous week and during
that class I proposed to my wife and she
accepted and I won the pencil that week
so it it's important I mean there's
certain you've got to be able to
communicate in life and it's enormously
important and probably the schools to
some extent under emphasize that I mean
you could start going for an MBA and
people think it's kind of beneath them
to teach you about communication but if
you if you can't communicate if you
can't talk to other people and get
across your ideas or write you know you
know you're giving up your potential and
you know anybody that's got her career
potential of X I guarantee it'll be 150
percent of x if they uh if they really
learn how to communicate well so that
was that was a big
a part of really succeeding in my career
because you made it
made a no I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome
if you want another amazing Warren
Buffett video check it out right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there